[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast où on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
baptiste super h 40 ans avec moi dôme
plantes
cette semaine au podcast en ont reçu
yannick de martino un humoriste qui
roule sa bosse depuis assez longtemps
qu'on voit de plus en plus partout mode
flash vous l'invitez parce qu'on aime
beaucoup on aime son style on trouve
drôle un petit peu absurde vraiment
différent de l'humoriste classique
finalement puis on l'abordé plainte et
aimait beaucoup justement comment qui a
développé son style comment qui a réussi
à assumer son style quoi sa méthode de
travail
ils continuent de signaler qu donne
vraiment drôles des ricains qui a fait
un spectacle est complètement calme en
tout après avoir fait un podcast avec my
world qui ça ça a mal tourné fait que tu
as mal drôle avec un belle rencontre
puis encore un beau pas de casque et si
vous voulez rejoindre notre communauté
sur pétri en histoire nous encourage et
puis avoir accès à du contenu exclusif
le lien va être dans la description la
vidéo ici
sinon abonnez-vous à notre chaîne
youtube parce qu'ils y voir des grosses
affaires qui s'en viennent pour nous
puis vous allez rester à l'affût comme
ceux de tous les podcasts qui vont
sortir encore à chaque semaine puis en
plus vous pouvez commenter sous la vidéo
ici
donnez vos impressions de l'addiction de
ton lit tous les commentaires on essaie
de répondre plus possible ça nous fait
plaisir de vous lire
ça nous fait plaisir aussi de voir que
vous nous suivez dans ce beau projet là
qui le sans-fil podcasts etc sans plus
attendre
bon podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
allô allô allô et essayent alémanique
merci ça fait plaisir l'invitation
ouais by that onu qui ont pignon sur le
podcast puis si on est pas qu à ce qu'on
ait le plus de fun parce que les
humoristes ont une répartition
c'était plus de mobiles connaissent et
de plantes un bon nom gpo et à
saint-hyacinthe longtemps fait que je
suis né là bas je lis juste le guil
parce que dit on et des maskoutains des
maskoutains espagne et 8 siffle comme je
sais pas pourquoi non je suis et puis je
vous sais c'est quand même un bon parti
d'andré un hybride un scout qui mascotte
couchant m est en moi je sais pas si les
jeunes mascouche s'écoule lentement
commencé
m à saint-hyacinthe est ce que ce rappel
dessus des premiers moments mais comment
comment a commencé de poètes à montréal
pour les gens scintillation in med est à
montréal pour le reste de du québec cet
été pour les gens qui viennent pas de
maurienne
morial pas loin de marjah ah ouais c'est
pas loin c'est comme 40 minutes mais
j'ai pas j'ai pas grandie labos par
exemple j'ai plus j'ai vraiment des
ménages est moins énormément de gens
pètent saint-jean-sur-richelieu montréal
j'ai pu attaquer bien qu'à dix vit à
saint romuald invités à lévis est assez
bonne période
un procédé que moi aussi je me suis
vraiment promener énormément donc j'ai
pas autant que je sais pas c'est quoi la
différence je savais que je ne pourrais
je pas resté longtemps quelque part une
visite est venu à montréal quatre
districts de refaire le monde hu à
exactement 7 faisait quoi j'ai commencé
quand même jeunes en fait j'étais jeune
et de finir le secondaire
j'ai eu un enfant à 18h - donc c'est ça
c'était vraiment comme tout de même
période puis je me cherchais comme pas
mal je savais pas que j'allais faire
c'est la manière en fait que mon j'ai
connu mon père et qui est décédé you see
donc
donc moi c'était particulier et
j'essaie de me sens simplement de l'âge
où elle va sortir si on veut mais triste
quand même pas m'en sortir
financièrement c'était vraiment sur le
plan émotif à l'avant c'est ce que j'ai
fait je faisais beaucoup d'improvisation
par année pour répondre au cégep
non non non mais choisit de les protéger
mais j'étais pas dans des éco j'avais
comme pas le temps parce que c'était
d'aller beaucoup de monde qui vivent
seules non c'est sa mère elle a continué
les études donc tiges et c'était sale et
se dirige par la suite cela l'est moins
pour le moment
opi puis je me suis lancée quand même
quand même mode comme mode de dire que
les jeunes qui doit le faire de l'humour
pour subvenir à ses besoins
axée sur quatre soirs par semaine elle
est ferme et au paiement mais mes
enfants et moi j'aimerais saluer mes
copains qui m'ont permis parce que ça a
commencé c'était un match
d'improvisation à saint-hyacinthe qu'il
ya une dynamique s'appelle samuel
tétreault qu'à l'époque on se connaît
c'est pau et cette soirée l'homme où je
suis j'ai ptet pas à saint-hyacinthe qui
se fait dans une période le jamais je
n'ai pas de taxes ou d'appartements
l'ipad appartement bien dit pas tant pis
moi c'est cette nuit et il me battre ici
côte venaient dormait chez nous on avait
connectés banal match d'un pôle mais
sait pas encore si c'est nos personnages
qui connecté vraiment l'espagne mais
appuie le gibier jeux fable puis le
lendemain on sait loin un appartement
ensemble
il croyait comme un amoureux potentiels
puis aussi c'est l'élu mais l'idée pour
n'avait écouté la série flight of the
conchords connaissez non c'est un duo
humoristique qui font de la musique ou
s'ils viennent de nouvelle-zélande qui
appartint new york pour faire de la
musique
en plus ça a été un bon mot finalement
web et maintenant il fait partie de mon
métier voire au début
non non non jamais mais j'ai tendu au
début par exemple un duo qui s'appelait
boxing five ok jamais joanisse ouais
c'est cool c'est moins recherchés à
rechercher de coin juste faisant un peu
le rock c'est très en plus c'est c'était
le
la première idée j'ai recherché on
parlait pas les documents du bac site
fire joie qu'elle est arrivée le pilote
a fait entre temps mon premier gala moi
qui savais que l'agent route la première
année c'est justement parce que
l'audition à la base j'avais fait est
que benjamin parfait dans ce port est
dit fallait je la fasse avec benjamin
qu'est-ce qu'on avait un numéro mais il
pouvait pas être là que j'ai fait le
numéro en solo mal expliqué mme kadio
avec mon mari parce que dans ce numéro
les jo qui marchait pas les vrais john
collins a mal été mais ça riait
tellement au bout je n'ai pas l'habitude
la personne qui fait le gag qui est à
côté de moi mais le mot là dessus
la jac le chic aux adjots plus rien mais
j'ai accepté
la pression monte et on retourne bolt
fait à l'audition j'aurai le nombre j'ai
fait à l'audition c'est vrai que avec
moins d'argent et de andy kaufman côté
de son numéro s'il y avait quelqu'un m'a
dit
[Rires]
une bonne histoire s'est terminée en
solo le dit chez tonton
non non mais lui le plus fort du théâtre
et où ils se retrouvaient plus en impro
mais de fil en aiguille ce n'est plus
moi qui écrivais et on faisait beaucoup
et non numérotés des liners page et ça
sort un peu du coq à l'âne qui on
faisait des chansons puis nos chances on
s'était promis de les traquer le monde
tripes et le plus filmé par tag sera des
liners assez naturellement je vais
montrer les liners mais moi je les
aimais automne y avait 2,2 tonnes qu'on
faisait souvent c'était il ya un
scorpion dans mon you go puis en gros ce
que c'est c'est ce qu'on disait qu'il
est scorpion appelé yoplait puis on
disait comme on laissant un message sur
leur boîte vocale en disant ça pas de
sens
il ya des scorpions en premier puis un
autre sur tes parents avec qui tu
expliquer comment tuer moi je vais aller
à tester quoi écoute bien qu'est-ce que
maudire cette fête et xau sur cette
agression de titres ids exauce parce
qu'évidemment il vient même à 100 tonnes
c'est quand même un peu ça faisait
vraiment léger lors de leur dépôt c'est
l'événement
c'était mignon ouest et remplacé show
partant de tamar par un crâne oui il ya
un deuxième départ il a attisé par
rapport à qui tu sûr que non par rapport
à parce que nous les gamins cet hexagone
stabat mater we hope
mais c'est surtout vrai mais je sais
tout avec la fois des guides sur code on
vous donne des conseils aux en fait il
faut qu'on joue que ça ça allait arriver
comme ceux qui sont armés des tribus
sahraouies grignote regardez regardez la
thématique des tubes dans ton humour au
fil du temps je me gare sur youtube où
est ce que tu fais tu chiale contre les
saveurs de cheap
ouais la seule vraie saveur c'est celle
yvinec 15/16 promettent de couilles tu
fais mal a également mené sans blague je
méritais même j'ai pas mal de job de
bouffe un jeu mérite et puis je me
disais je penche doivent au maintien
même nourriture ou de quoi passionner
debout faut que je réfléchisse j'aime la
nourriture j'aimerais manger mais on est
maîtres et mi6 mimi midi ne sont pas aux
dirigeants recevant non je suis j'ai
vraiment aucune idée
le e mo mais les saveurs j'avoue c'est
plus comme ça va je trouvais trop
d'absents ça va mais parce qu'à cause
des berlines je pensais aux savoirs de
sloche pas mal comment menez était bonne
absurde et savoir de sluch tapis je
pense quand je suis jeune par exemple un
souvenir qui m'ont marqué
- ça vraiment remis la sloche sa amap
les couche-tard ont fait un gros mot
votre la sla celle qu'on avait oublié la
sloche a longtemps douté slash propice à
rappeler pull ouahbi eux ils y ont
trouvé le truc ça vend à cela cela tu
devais te dire comme tu avais dit ce fan
c'est comme trois minutes après c'était
fini loin tu avais juste de la glace
qu'il y avait de l'eau froide puis au
lion mais on aurait pu penser qu'elles
émettent moins de glace nom vient au
gros c est par une glace plus vite qu'en
dit mettons la grosse cloche au
couche-tard quand tu peux mettre ton
quatre sortes de dinde
c'était tellement gros alors avoir
tellement de sucre dans sur le disque on
faisait maintenant c'est à dire des
étages le gameplay un petit peu de blues
j'en avais envie de vomir métal infligé
à toi le juste debout je faisais truc de
rap c'est jose cobo qui mettait le
couvent ça glisse un peu sur le côté
parce que y'a n'était pas étanche parce
que je montais couper ses partisans mais
il n'y a pas de savoir c'était rouge
bleu est une couleur blanche tout ce
poème écrit zahia les secours ne l'était
pas ce que j'aimais faste et les laisser
forme tranquillement pas pu prendre le
jeu à fond
je crois que je réalise je me suis dit
crime si ce que j'aime c'est le jus tu
allais prendre avant que soient gelés
sauf que le casque des lames est venu le
must écrit c'est dégueulasse on ne fait
que regarder comprendre pourquoi je
tripais vraiment ce que jouer à fond
bout de jus ça s'appelle mr freeze beau
dessin insultant
ce plat pour le monsieur non mamoutou
[Musique]
[Rires]
inimaginable et qu'alors je t'encule
ailleurs on osait moyens ouais c'est ça
doit être cool à voir maintenant ça doit
être vraiment challenge en avant
l'enfant à 18 ans mais le terran dire
que l'âge de 28 ans
merci mais avoir un kid de 11 ans quant
à 30 ans à peut-être temps quand même
wyatt coup de com mais honnêtement moi
j'ai vraiment j'ai vraiment une belle
relation que mon fils qui plus con que
convient plus qu'on se rapproche plus
aussi jeune veau qui est de plus en plus
fier de son passé une relation que c'est
si rare que cela en fait une relation
père fils ressemble la seule vue là haut
j'ai titre continue d'évoluer énormément
18 à 30 ans il souvent les gens ont des
enfants plus prétendantes et leur
personnalité commence pas mal a
cristallisé si on veut leur carrière
c'est ce puits moi la seule
le seul truc en fait quand même pas à
pas avec lui mais plus la pression de
faire quelque chose de réussir ça vient
vite il ya des horaires plus vite
ouais vraiment donc moi je me souviens
il ya en fait je me dise vrai que plein
de moments que j'aimerais revivre
maintenant en sachet ça va bien aller un
jour où il ya plein de bamako
même si j'ai quand même d'aider des
beaux souvenirs et je me dis qu allen
j'aurais pu tellement plus en profiter
mais j'étais en train de me dire à créon
je sais pas comment ça va aller je sais
pas moi m'en sortirais pas que cela
fasse fonctionner du monde c'est l'image
que je pense que je les ai été j'aurais
pu ne plus light
à un moment j'ai continué de live juste
par habitude mais ouais je pense à moi
j'ai commencé vraiment à réussir à
m'enlever de la pression chez elle est
vraiment être il ya une heure ou deux
même après avoir gagné un mois parce que
j'avais quand même style à moins qu'ils
quand un singulier
j'étais pas la personne qu'on engage est
en excès d'un mbj une carrière moi
j'aime vraiment la carrière maintenant
que j'ai parce que je pense que j'ai pu
vraiment à comprendre aux gens ce que je
fais et puis j'ai eu le temps aussi
vraiment de si je trouve que pendant à
rothesay pas encore arrivée à maturité
j'ai l'impression qu'on me fait gagner
plus pour mon potentiel que qu'est ce
que je propose est dans le moment
l'originalité aussi sans doute je pense
que oui mais je calmerais coûte
maintenant je crois que je suis ailleurs
publicis avait décollé comme trop
rapidement je pense je n'aurais pas eu
le temps de commander deux d'aller
trouver qui que je suis profondément et
ensuite de sommes en servir comme
artiste
il aurait juste continuer à développer
leur dialogue continu et que ça
fonctionne bien mais vu que les
sentiments menée auprès de 100 à des
pages et plus se référer réfléchi je
vous souhaite respecter
je pense que je fais quelque chose
quelque chose de plus organique que ce
avait décollé d'un coup moi sans doute
il pense tu que cette période du ces le
ça a été le moteur je mens à écrire à
essayer d affaires à vouloir deux fois
plus souvent par ce succès avait pas eu
cette difficulté le
tu aurais peut-être pas là aujourd'hui
oui je comprends pas en fait quand même
apte à fonctionner ce moment là parce
que j'aurais pu faire un niveau en étant
sûr ça fonctionne mais jallet puis ça
m'a pris j'ai vraiment pas un humour de
banc j'arrivais à défaut d'être horrible
ça les pousse pas habillé mais je pense
j'avais tellement à rien que je me dis
c'est la seule chose que j'ai faite de
coups qui me fait rire le qui me fait
vraiment rire et j'ai comme plus lent à
vis de d'absolument que tout le monde
aime ce que je fais ou essayer puis
emmené après coup une chose parfait
parce que quand on sait que tout le
monde termes la personne qui t'a dans
tout le monde et comme beaucoup il
existe 6 mai mais j'essaie pour ça a été
mon mandat j'ai aucune deux ans
nettement
je ne compte pas de driver
nécessairement par le succès je pense
que vraiment c'est vraiment un motif
juste me prouver à moi même que j'étais
capable de faire quelque chose
c'est vraiment intéressant de d'imaginer
après ça avec la la rétrospective de ce
que te de ce que te par quoi te passer
en fait d'imaginer de pouvoir le voir
cette personne ne disait que ça va être
correct
ouais c'est j'aurais parlé je me
rappelais plus c'était soit un podcast
bien sur une autre page pétrole mais
louis sic et qui maintenant il peut
tomber des grosses le mais lui disais si
j'avais pu me donner un message à mon
moi c'était juste de dire et relax
traquer pilule le gros family tendance à
durer un an et demi wells très peu de sa
faute de pouvoir d'avoir la conscience
puis la lucidité de pouvoir te dire
crime j'aurais aimé savoir ce qu'en fait
quand ça se passe à 29 c est quand même
passé parce que je pense que de besoin
des doutes pour avancer puis foncé six 6
mois du présent à l'evo mois du parce
qu'ils disaient aïe ça en ben ali je
pense que le mot du futur appareil
c'est l'effet papillon la touche
justement tu as un style vraiment
singulier ses piques carbure au malaise
un peu de foi dans ton humour j'ai
l'impression bamba etc où la houle et
l'absurde ça c'est sûr je pense oui en
fait ce que je peux non mais c'est quoi
rajouter mais je la justice apprend du
god pareille à une soirée ça va pas bien
tenir ton but vide non non moi c'est ce
c'est ça mon style du mot puis je veux
trouver man et je peux trouver mon
public l'adaptateur d'ajuster justement
pirates ça marche mais je dois me vois
même normaliser un petit peu mais en
fait
je dirai pas qui carbure au miles mais
je suis prêt à l'accepter quelques fois
parce que j'ai l'impression que les
mêmes idées qu'une fois dans l'autre que
dans mon col qui quitte vraiment ça
fonctionne vraiment beltaine pic ce que
les gens savent et fait vraiment rire
mais c'est les mêmes idées des fautes
légères
il aime passer du tube qui sont aux
commandes on le sait trop si c'est trop
fauqué mais en 2010 il faut le sait je
suis content car les jeux conscient que
ça polarise et un moment donné je me
suis juste habitués à un peu habité ce
mal à les lapider interagir avec les
gens pendant ce moment enveloppes et des
fois même décortiquer le le pourquoi en
ce moment à leur insu yves pau puis j'ai
réalisé que cette façon quand même des
gens qui décrochent eux ils finissent
par ray parce qu'ils se rendent compte
que je suis pas dans une psychose
puis-je totalement lucide pigeon hill ce
qu'est ce que je propose je pense
qu'avec le temps aussi je l'espère
normalisée mais j'ai pris confiance par
contre en mes moyens et maintenait jusix
intérêt pour de vrai je pense que le
malaise aussi jeune et des fois que je
lançais mon idée j'attends de voir si
ces indigents ce comics mais maintenant
j'assume plus
et justement je pense que quand il ya
une forme de malaise soit parce que je
parle dans un délire mais au moment où
quelqu'un qui va au rire du tout qui va
voir ses l'appli le turc le moins aimé
ya quelqu'un à côté qui va faire une
annonce enfin j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui me disaient qu'en général ils
tiraient pas sur lui mots qui me disait
toi
j'aime / donc ça ça me fait plaisir mais
je me dis pour les mecs c'est parce que
je fais quelque chose de plus organique
quelque chose c'est si ça doit se
transmettre par fait que ça que ça me
fait vraiment rire là parce qu'il ya en
eux que tu fais c'est très efficace mais
tu m'as tu leur parles dans la vie
puisse paraître on dirait que tes
blagues je pense pas que ces choses qui
s'adonnent faire rigoler mais qu'est ce
qui te fait vraiment répondrai que c'est
pas son envie que ça fonctionne et tout
est bon et c'est normal puis y'a pas de
mal à ça ne se joue pas en train de
critiquer mais dans mon cas - je suis là
dans mon job je répète aucun cas ça va
un peu moins bien je pourrais vous
rihour il vous riez pas ce jeu moi je
faisais des affaires qui me plaît je
pars femme parce que comme n'importe qui
qui fait quoi
mais j'aime les idées que que je propose
pas ce métier comme comme seul outil
chute un peu comme je pense n'importe
quel créatif juste un peu bipolaires
dans mon appréciation mais en général je
suis
j'assume qu'est ce que je dis c'est pour
ça aussi que série au pauvre ben je le
couvrais paul james e par exemple chez
krt numéro ya justement ce internet puis
c'est un gag tic qu'à ce moment là le
public et le jury pas vraiment plus de
fait ben moi j'aime vraiment mon humour
parce que dans le fond c'est drôle très
bonne façon de récupérer les choses à 12
h 10 camarades métier je peux dire
carbure au fait que le monde sont en
salle puis jean son nom pétrifié ce
jeudi dès fois ci laissé ce qui est
drôle aussi un peu perdus ou ne sait pas
trop où justement les remettant le
numéro de compte explique est en étude
ok bello
le gone 10 heures puis le sait encore
mais c'est alors exact compris non je
comprenne si je réponds à une belle
carrière si je carbure est je sais moi
aussi c'est tout un honneur mais j'en
ajoute qu'un manque un cas que des jo
qui fonctionne big time j'aime ce
acheter des fois comme je t'emmène de
marmonner un petit quelque chose qu'on
comprend mal cette crise qui est dit si
je n'ai même pas moi même ce que j'ai
dit c'est vraiment juste pour rester au
jérôme distincts et des écoles gérées
par joe qui marche
je m'amuse vraiment au début il faut
qu'ils aient des enfants jamais mais qui
avait aucun rapport
les agents des informations je parlais
semaine il ya en fait avant ça je
marmonnait les enfants c'est maintenant
chose ndjock sait pas très bien entendu
deux parties meilleur segment de la g
hier j'écoutais
sous écoute avec toi puis julien comme
lui comme je disais avant le podcast
aucun média mike qui disait parce qu'on
s'entend que julien putois vous avez un
humour qui est semblable qui pas qui est
pas pareil mais qui est qui est sa
blague qui se rejoint sur plusieurs mois
mais il le sait puis mike qui disent il
ya beaucoup d'humoristes qui qui sont
bons mais tu veux les voir petit ça
ressemble à ça sert c'est ma force et ma
soeur sont dont le numéro est bon ça te
fait rire mais maïs qui disait ce qui
vous distingue vous deux puis elle vous
parlez à vous deux phases distinctes
sûrement d'autres mondes aussi mais
c'est l'unicité
c'était c'est de l'humour qui est unique
si l'humour que des fois ça peut ne pas
avoir le plus de réussir mais au moins
ça va être original je pense qu'il est
vraiment beaucoup de mérite à sûr ça ça
parait au long terme j'ai l'impression
dans un succès sur une plus longue
période de temps et c'est même chose
mais dont mike justement le tient des
réunions qui est encore qu'à l'islande
roule maintenant c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'autres qui font ce que lui fait le tir
parce qu'ils aient beaucoup d'humoristes
de son art de sa génération qui sont
juste disparu parce que ce qu'il faisait
ça ressemble un peu à ce que toutes les
autres faisaient bloc le fait que j'ai
l'impression que pour perdurer dans le
temps pour avoir un public le public de
mike ward se prendre un public le plus
fidèle au québec le monde a l'impression
que le tweet suivant un peu d'un
d'impôts dans ce public là mais dans la
même direction auch précisé devoir avons
un public qui est vraiment attaché à toi
pourquoi un public qui aime rire parce
qu un public qui aime rire tu peux aller
boire n'importe quel humoriste varier
beaucoup d'humoristes soit passé une
soirée mettant aucun humoriste fait la
salle albert-rousseau à québec que tu
rire au paul sauf que mais que tu vas
sortir de là où tout s'était giry je
pense que d'avoir une niche comme ça
tout ça tu m'étonnes moutons public 38e
vraiment créer une espèce de deux corps
de fans qui tripent sur toi tu sais qui
je suis
je laisse à mes mains qu'on parlait en
fait j'ai senti aussi que justement
d'avoir soumis dès le départ
ma singularité j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui dégeilh comprennent mieux
je suis qu'ils puissent se sont d'une
certaine manière peut-être je sais pas
si c'est trop forte a pas attaché mais
ils comprennent mieux du moins un bon
petit pipi j'ai l'impression mannequin
j'arrive dans un galop et tout s'éclaire
à star pis maintenant c'est plus le cocu
un lien expo nécessairement ballon sur
sa plainte certaine partie du public que
maintenant pour de vrai
habituellement quand une fois faire un
galop wever les gens sont contents ça
détonne
puis je pense que on compare souvent à
la place du public quant à le public qui
y comprennent poppy mais non mais les
mêmes choses c'est pas nécessairement
qu'est ce qui te demande ce qu'est ce
que tu leur impose toi au final il ya
dedans mais sa représentante
c'est mon rodage de one man show je
réalise que j'ai un super que des
spectateurs en fait plus large que je
pensais j'ai déjà tout âge il ya c'est
pas nécessairement tout cas il y en a
des défauts des très jeunes que pour eux
c'est beau c'est ce que je fais mais il
yad'autres gd je suis à veendam n'ya pas
longtemps qu'elle a capoté parce quand
même emmené dans mon show en fait mon
spectacle il ya une bonne partie de choc
si je propose des néologismes que j'ai
inventé des nouveaux mots madame ça
allait mais ce puits à la haye la
reconnaissance est justement d'aider à
trouver sont intelligents et entrepôts
ce juste super doux juste trop farfelue
puis un tu te rends compte que pas mal
tout le monde détenait cherche quelque
chose de différent animaux il y en a
tellement consommer certainement été
élevé au québec que maintenant je vois
pas de g oui j'ai comme un bassin de
fans que c'est des vrais de vrais fans
qui me suivent depuis le départ mais
j'ai l'impression même si c'est
peut-être même grâce à eux que ça ça le
com a été plus loin que je sais qu'ils
maintenaient ya eu pas mal bâti bâton
les dénis aussi
nous gagnons on parle encore comme si
mais quand l'insee ça marchera pas à
cette heure là où ça fonctionne big time
maintenant cdc même plus une vraie
analyse de dire comment est cependant
pour une valeur sûre lettonie c'est même
en hiver est le public c'est mal
malgré ces mâles jojo email exact mais
je suis loin d'un historien de l'humour
québécois mais je me rappelle que quand
les premiers clips de jean thomas jobin
sont sortis en ligne qu'on avait accès à
cette espèce d'humour complètement hors
du des chantiers battus le rappelle que
ce mot j'avais fait
oh oui ça se peut de pagis faire des
gags qui font du sens très peu de faire
de l'humour absurde chasse peu ce genre
d'humour l'up
on dirait puis c'est possiblement qui a
eu des précurseurs avant jean thomas
jobin a fait très certainement mais moi
je me rappelle avoir vu après ce les
codes un peu l'humour explosé j'ai
l'impression
je sais pas qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais c'est l'impression que j'ai eue
petit je voudrais encore là il manque
beaucoup d'années pour un capable de
vraiment bien je ne sais pas parce que
je n'ai jamais été un kir à
consommateurs du monde non plus par
contre je me souviens que pour moi aussi
quand j'avais vu jeter comme jeune
adolescent quand j'ai vu jean thomas
puis denis et francky qui fait du liner
comme venir les cheveux longs un peu
personnages même si quand j'avais vu ces
trois là or quand l'équipe à ce
qu'avance du mot ça me parlait pas
nécessairement j'avais vraiment sur
l'impro mais l'humour des il faut
j'avais de la difficulté à me
reconnaître ces 10 gt gt en fait aimer
les les idées puis les lire les
propositions qui partent vraiment de
l'imaginaire et puis j'ai de la misère à
le voir un numéro au québec d'ouest
veste est très anecdotique
puis sam ça me faisait patrie prix mais
quand j'ai vu ces trois horloges à ok il
ya d'autres moteurs de ce samedi
ça va vraiment marqué puis sa partie du
g20 j'aimerais ça j'aimerais ça faire de
l'humour mais le cac wac est ce qui me
vient en tête du parti elle vient
stéphane fallu aussi quitté vient à mon
école céderons jamais reparlé fallu puis
j'avais comme non mais ça c'est mr n'ont
pas mis au monde
puis j avais dit comme après le show et
parler je sors un peu les a aimés du
secteur que j'aime et j'ai messi depuis
j'aimerais pas souffert de limogeage en
14 et il me donne une adresse courriel
de gym avait dit en mai et a besoin d'un
blabla qui a été vraiment gentil et le
finalement il me répond jamais et le
baril j ai dit moi un de trop il a fallu
à la plus petite à petit toute attente
en juillet pour un jeune qui dit est il
mort mais je pense à castres où je fais
vraiment attention
je sais que peut-être que si tu me
quittes à écrire au japon mais j'essaie
vraiment des cris quand même mais
surtout et facebook aujourd'hui beaucoup
de jeunes et beaucoup de jeunes que
justement il reproduit vie
nécessairement facile et tout donc ses
juges si je peux juste donné un petit
coup de mou y sa part sur les réseaux
sociaux n'est quand même pas mal bâti je
sais pas je comprends pas avec d'autres
mais pas mouche vraiment pour réseaux
sociaux ont tenté et réécrit ça me
demande vraiment de l'énergie donc pour
moi deux c'est beaucoup et en mettant ça
fait appeler israël fait vraiment
plaisir c'est vraiment juste de me
connecter mais
je m'amuse à présent quand j'ai commencé
il y en avait pas vraiment de réseaux
sociaux j'étais mieux mais
personnellement j'ai culpabilisé des
succès nécessaire parce qu'on a besoin
absolument eux je pense à le
démocratiser certainement les langues
c'est certain je pense que ça allait
vraiment donné un second souffle à ma
carrière ça allait bien mais truc mais
quand j'ai commencé à mettre en ligne
des ddd dit que j'écrivais des statuts
que je partageais des blagues et tout
c'est le qu'on pensait plus à moins télé
tout donc salsa mot vrai mais vraiment
servi vraiment beaucoup
c'est juste de bien d'autres et j'ai
demandé tout sans coupable
aujourd'hui j'ai pas peur de quoi
je me dis je je pourrais faire un story
lopy ce soir est reconnue en estrie dix
fois ci c'est quand même fou plus jamais
ça à malte pour être plus connu à
melbourne j'ai model of mana ses matons
laon volley julien lacroix tic sont fait
connaître avec des sketches sur internet
il y est
comment elle s'appelle elle qui était
sur marvin john coates avec et avec ses
capsules humoristiques sur une telle
impression c'est la nouvelle façon de
reconnaître ses torts anthony
contournable de d'être critiques ont eu
tout le temps sur les réseaux sociaux de
ce mois je peux je pense que oui mais en
même temps si si si vous voulez
travailler pareil
puis au-delà du travail c'est la santé
mentale parce que madani dessus dessous
cd je sais déjà quand même compliqué à
la base
dissocier personnalités publiques les
personnalités dans la vie met ton égo de
côté ses lego si ça sert à rien c'est
juste cccb y en a en fait que ça fait
avancer mais je pense pas par exemple du
niveau humain à la personne et
ce qui étoffent par bull parce que m'a
donné des quatre personnages et réseaux
sociaux puisque 10 story c'est à toutes
les intelligences encourage la dette
j'ai l'impression qu'il a profondément
toi sauf que moi c'est ce que j'ai de la
difficulté puis ou si ses juges et mon
propre contenu hl mois ses défauts mais
pourquoi chiffre 7 sont déjà regardé des
fois des enfants je fais pourquoi
demande trouverais ça intéresse
j'ai écouté ton blog
qu est ce que tu faisais je suppose
qu'avec qui sait où est ce que vous
devinez les objets avec les yeux bandés
au teil maría une arbalète manette juste
à gaza exactement
c'est cette idée cette parodie de ce
type de blog il faut que je vois c'est
18 minutes de coma eyeliner on est fous
parce qu'on parlait contre la pub
pendant un bout de tapis tout le monde
est devenu une poupe en ce moment puis à
vallauris c'est que je trouvais ce karim
herouat ça c'est mon ami ont trouvé sa
grande période et on amène jeune couple
qui comme ça me rappelle c'est exact il
s'est passé quoi mais là tu viens la
merde je ne porte jamais par chelsea
s'est bien passé même pas en guerre sont
séparés parce que toutes les raisons il
ya des guerres melty show que je le
porte
je sais pas non mais je les mines même
la presse ont exprimé un avis qui
faisait aussi c'est vraiment non partie
c'était juste des sentiments intimes et
instituteurs mais c'est le sport
mais c'est ça moi je trouve ça m
je trouve que ça c'est magnifique des
réseaux sociaux c'est que tout le monde
peut faire celui du contenu je faisais
mon rôle et des bas mais citons contenu
est bon il va se faire voir ces pisse à
ses coaches trouve deux types y mettons
ce genre de sketches le le le cela n'a
pas fait beaucoup encore mais suffit
d'en faire un petit peu plus la
fréquence constante le pi
ça va ça va te faire voir ça touche la
coop secolo site pas passer par un
producteur
quel producteur m'aurait dit ouais non
je touche une année à neige dictateur
ben ali parce que c'est jamais j'écris
je t'amène syrie c'est un one man show
one pedn et l'autre va dire non puis ça
raconte que ces personnes ont créé
d'autres exemples mais on s'éduque stage
juste pour femmes
le projet mais c'est vrai que c'est
qu'au de faire ce parti j'ai une série
aussi que j'ai fait avec julien la
croche la main ces appels des prodiges
et là on va faire une saison 2 et le
sait c'est que l'on est du financement
pour la saison 2 mais messi coupe parce
que je pense pas que ce genre de projets
qui ont été financés non si ça avait été
juste sur papier mais le vie quand on a
eu sa fin de saison avec nos moyens
puissent ou de causer qui est une petite
boîte de production ben alors ok mais
l'auteur vraie démonstration un vrai
pilote est plus qu avant la fête c'est
ce qui c'est plate à dire mais c'est des
producteurs lyon duchère
ouais je sais pas si est venue l'idée
que les chiffres je crois que c'est dit
et je le sais que c'est poli des mousses
et les deux kivu meilleur des mondes si
on avait eu une discussion avec françois
l'embarras parce que l'ancien dragon il
était venu sur le podcast si on avait
une discussion par rapport à aux
subventions aux artistes versus le lui
il y avait une obligation de rendement
des régimes et d'avoir accès à des
premières à une technologie à ses chips
commission dispose pas cheap à 100% mais
je veux dire c'est pas un million de
dollars à voir le jour à lyon n'est qu'à
ces cas pas de produire des difficultés
de la distribution démocratiser comme le
web ça permet justement de faire ce de
créer du contenu d'une qualité x de voir
les résultats de ce corner puis après
c'est ok le système mon budget c'est les
résultats
est-ce que vous embarquer là dedans
c'est cela permet de me baï passé le
système dette obligés d'attendre des
subventions est en jeu datant même
principe que la musique n'importe quelle
forme d'art dans le fond le tir on est
comme le podcast on ne peut pas nier des
calmes des micros on n'est pas une
chaîne youtube puis en sprint et on met
tout ça en ligne puis hop aucune télé
aucune radio qui nous a dit qu'on est
obligé à temps la prime radio pitcher le
projet de radio c'est comme tu es enfant
tu le penses aaron sapin si c'est bon ça
vos poignets pitié je trouve ses
trousses et on vit dans une bonne époque
pour les autres je trouve vraiment
belles portes pour de rire pour aussi
moche à sedan et humoriste pour ça parce
que je peux produire beaucoup de contenu
que dans le fond les gens ont pas de
besoin d'acheter ou rim ça me fait de la
bonne publicité puis ensuite de tous
âges plus j'ai des billes avant tout
pour moi
qui vidait il ya un vrai impact joie
puis qui me permet d'encore de bien
vivre grâce à ce ça m'encourage à faire
du contenu parce que je compte encore
déjà il trouve ça rigolo et rigolo on a
fait ces commentaires je vous allez voir
ce spectacle je fais je fais du coup
rien à voir avec avec le monde matériel
de sur sa lancée et puis surtout ça
c'était elle a en plus je contacterai
par les sept capsules de parce que
c'était vraiment une nécessité la
première capsule que dans le fond on
réalisait tout seul on a fait le montage
voûte mon ami j'ai même pu d'équipés de
tournage c'est vraiment jeu en nous une
caméra sur trépieds soir ça marche
tc mais moi j'ai rien cinq minutes je le
sais c'est aussi là que ça puis il ya
des projets jeu il ya des projets par
contre que j'aime vraiment la belle
réalisation
pitié le principe un peu pour faire le
pari que la musique me fais de la
musique dans vie avec la démocratisation
de la musique avec un site de streaming
ça fait qu'elle sait plus vraiment en
faisant une toune que tu as de l'argent
tu les clics c'est comme ça donne des
scènes par par écoute un mois des
millions des millions de personnes
seraient affectées se pose pas avec ce
que tu fais de l'argent sauf que ce que
ça permet de faire c'est d'amener le
monde à thé chaud très chaud à ta mère
ta mémoire et et shoah mais moins tu as
much pis ce c'est juste bon team
maintenant il ya beaucoup de monde mais
ton les vieux de la vieille qui vendait
quand les semaines des albums frank
inquiet ce thème la seule façon d plus
de la musique c'est d'acheter des albums
fait quatre vingt pièces à mettre votre
note sur un ben que tu sais que c'est
bon chemin band émergents que tu connais
pas autant le mettre sur un banc que tu
sais que c'est bon t'es quand on était à
100 m pour acheter un album parce que le
monde qui change le plus sur ses pattes
formule 1 de streaming c'est le monde
qui était établi puis qui sont un peu
chez qui promettait que je peux plus
faire des mails
on juste avec en vendant mes albums faut
que je fasse de l'argent avec des shows
parce que voilà qui ont le plus de
mesures
c'est ce système qui change c'est ce que
kant et habitudes 30 façon ça change
tout ça l'a bien pour toi c'est sûr que
le tue son alambic la marche pas est ce
que le site est maintenant du streaming
est parfait je pense que l'on est de
l'autriche en aucun cas y est tellement
d'artistes qu'on n'aurait même pas sa
start up a pu enregistrer rien je pense
que ça sera déjà plus curieux c'est dès
qu'ils commencent maintenant c'est
possible comme contretemps
ouais tu ta musique est bonne c'est
parce que qu'ils entendent qui se remet
et il ya encore et encore maintenant dix
ans pas de fermer ton c'est avant tout
dans une playlist métayer tout un jeu de
coulisse pareil tu connais quelqu'un ça
existe encore se lever quand même bien
compris ici je connais quelqu'un juste
non non mais tu sais où tu engages une
firme des pilleurs qui vont commencer
pour tout à fait factice et l'est encore
ça mais il a moins il ya encore celui-là
petipa départ d'endeavour ont contredit
ce que c'est sony pub se met
médecin c'est peu quand même sortir de
la musique qui est bonne piqué à soi
juste dans la mer de trucs bonté puis
pilote métis plus que sa pop world blues
souvent non animaux c'est la même
affaire au québec jeu des placements
gouache et il ya tout un été bon elle
que puis je pense l année passée au lieu
de 2,5 est juste mais juste olivier
primo que yaya miami sur sa page
pêcheurs de cesser de tomber sous la
tentation de quelqu'un qui attention
comme des guinguettes un ancien malade
mental c'est un ancien que d'une
invisible que l'oeil fait des
conférences sur dépassement de soi et
c'est vraiment fou sa carrière était
comme au point un autre joe hogan
entendu parler son histoire il invitait
son podcast
il allègue t d'organes face à la
macédoine
taiana foule d'amis lui lui était était
vraiment jangle l'a invité pour son
histoire principe pas parce qu'il est
connu lundi pour son histoire plein
vitalité à la jungle une histoire
raisonnée que les fans de glee millions
c'est juste juste j'ai du temple c'est
avec faso des iut sa carrière allait
bien je pense maîtrise est loin d'être
humoriste dans les plus visibles au
québec suffit qu'ils disent oui à une
affaire passée
il ya ici tu es je pense quand même
demandé à domont avance à 30,8 et qui
ont refusé parce que tu te dis -6 jouer
à ce poste un flop
ça peut être nesta chamond affaire aussi
le type ici pilote dit oui à 6
finalement grosse exposure fixe face une
story et georges total place devant des
bleus s'est vendu directive qui est des
fois c'est une affaire peu
soutien et à carrière d'abord le bar en
bas rhinois puis en humour en plus au
québec
j'ai aucune statistique à l'appui mais
j'ai vraiment l'impression que
ratio pour la population d'humoristes au
québec c'est excessivement élevés je
peux rester en pense le gène vraiment
beaucoup de gens qui consomment
d'humoristes au québec
pour l'heure cette population je pense
que oui mais je ne sais pas parce que
j'ai posée parce que mettront tous vos
jeux ça new york je pense qu'il ya un an
mais il ya tellement monde où seulement
de monde mais je pense que le ratio le
pour ça ressemble et d'après moi parce
que j'ai été moi parce que mais coincé
ça j'ai été à new york il ya pas
longtemps j'ai été pour le fendant 2 3
open mic et tout le monde faisait du
stand up mais des gens qui ça fait
vraiment partir de cultures aussi pour
juste c'est même plus des humoristes
font le stand-up c'est tout le monde est
petit je trouvais ça vraiment a beau
avoir une forme d'expression vous y
verrez plus jamais cela la figue il y
avait une fille qui avait pris de force
de sa pause à pharmacie à côté est venu
voir son stand-up parce que tu es fort
chez piste et a parlé d'un anecdote qui
venait d'y arriver d'une cliente chiante
c'est nice la saison laisse penser que
jeudi le ratio le gsm j'assume ce
pourcentage ou aucune doit pourtant jeu
je ne sais pas mais bref j'en ai quand
même énormément beaucoup mais j'ai
clairement mais je pense que c'est parce
que tout le monde nous si il y en a
beaucoup de talent mais je pense c'est
le genre de job que tout le monde aurait
voulu faire parce que deux qui a dit que
tout le monde se donne c'est drôle et
intelligent correctement et a pu
dépasser en double je suis drôle c'est
quand une subjectivité ça se peut bien
qu'avec tmi la mémoire pour
l'intelligence des matons le conte il
comprend de repos quelques de spoil
intelligent
nécessairement intelligent il va
peut-être le trouver en moyenne des
cours
aussi je propose 16 10 et yves jacques
boudreau pas drôle mais mais ces deux
quintiq te montre persuadé d éclat mais
surtout si c'est avec les mots parce que
des foyers déjà qu'ils sont persuadés
les comics mais ils sont habitués aux 6
2 en plus en fait question s'ils n'ont
pas peur du ridicule avec la personne
qui fait saliver drôme et l'usld
qu'est-ce qui fait c'est s'est allumé
ces ip at&t que les oui les jeunes
guéris mais je sais pas quel point ce
que c'est parce que tu es un bien c'est
sûr que c'est pas en équilibre sur trois
[Rires]
mais à mes yeux c'est pour bourrer pour
le ratio le d'ailleurs mes yeux oui pas
mal d'humoriste est ce que tu penses que
comme un espèce de changement dans la
vieille garde au niveau de l'humour au
québec j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
vraiment un cycle qui et qui est rapide
avec toutes les humoristes émergents qui
viennent de
premièrement plus juste de l'école de
l'humour comme comme tu as un bon
exemple j'ai la croix guillaume pineau
qu'on a reçues et moi viennent pas de
l'école et l'humour en espèces de
changement dans le paysage mais vos vies
je veux dire que certaines personnes qui
étaient établis peuvent un peu tombé
tomber popo tombe est tombé des nues
l'un peut perdre leur leur piédestal
jusqu'à y était pire à avoir en fait à
refaire leur place dans ce paysage là ça
se prend maintenant moi je pense que
c'est bien qu'il mord je trouve que les
mots hisse au québec c'est tellement
populaire que je pense pour ceux des
fois qu'on est moins habitué à os c'est
vraiment différent
j'ai l'impression que quand on mène on
veut du thème apposé des étiquettes
d'absurde
oliver voilà va tailler tondre et de
l'originalité c'est de blues pour un
artiste donc que - s'est rendu
lui c'est l'humoriste qui est original
qui va ailleurs
dans ma tête j'ai fini là parce que
quand j'écoute mettant des stand-up
ctspace netflix ça vaut dans toutes les
zones la majorité du stand-up louis
siquet tout le monde est cool avec ça je
pense qu'à qu'on vient voir mon
spectacle
c'est chaud aussi ne suis-je pas déjà
c'est pas moi d'étape sur je ne sais pas
de rien il faudra juste des trucs que
j'ai envie de dire mais par bout d'un an
mené on m'avait dit de désirade et
décider vraiment des femmes seulement
qu'ils me suivaient beaucoup nous ont
été surpris par des relations
hommes-femmes c'est vrai mais je traîne
du manque beaucoup de coaches doivent
emmener sa femme et lui mais peut
supposer que j'ai un numéro classique
parce que
c'est un sujet classe et j'ai mes
visions à moins mon anglais - je
trouvais ce particulier d'êtres humains
qui ville et aborde des thèmes un peu
plus universel comme décor comme si de
base je me donnais moralement à d'être
tout le temps absorbe tout est d'aller
dans des sujets qui qui qui sont qui
sont différents et tous peints en défaut
qu'est ce qui m'a bien je lui dis j'en
parlais et c'est tout je pense c'est
pour ça c'est tellement devenu comme
populaire l'humour comme emmenons
s'habituer à un type du monde avec les
galeries tout c'était tout à des
producteurs les premiers programmes ans
de galère qui allait pour selon eux du
sort chats
donc c'était un peu il y avait tout de
temps en temps quelqu'un pour qui
détonnait mais c'est tout en europe
c'est tout est à lui ou rdc la personne
wild d'accès tout comme vite
ok les hobbies sont celles de la grèce à
eux c'est plus classique
on dirait on sait comment à penser comme
ça puis présentement mouche trousseau
colleu que l'humour se démocratise parce
qu'il ya du monde qui qui à mon style
comme je dit à l'armée qui est un pôle
l'humour en général ces gens là
peut-être que dans le teil en aurait pu
écouter de galio ça leur part les mots
justement parce qu'il ya une impression
que lui mots c'était un peu tout le
temps
la même chose ça se ressemble et d'un
numéro un autre pilote présentement il
ya plein de gens disent ce qu'ils
quitteraient plus ce rosé de vaillants
ac au cse rosalie ce qui trait sur
julien c'est sûr julien août il dit puis
moi je trouve ça parfait comme seul je
sais pas s'il y en a qui perdent leur
leur piédestal
je manquais leur public ont signé suivre
ces gens là pareil le temps c'est aussi
un tout nouveau public et qui émerge
tout le temps c'est en même temps qu'ils
ont tous appuyé piano et c'est pas mal
cyril santé c'est une bonne chose en
fait si apprécié à ce point leur
piédestal savoir que cette meilleure
pour qu'est-ce qu'ils vont créer
prochainement de retomber un peu parce
qu'ils avaient l'impression d'avoir un
peu le monopole
parce qu'il s'était tout en re compenser
pour faire de latérite ou pas tu sais
juste propose ainsi je sais même
possible pour réussir c'est pas
longtemps que fait ce médecin
le désir de rester shirt de se
renouveler de rester dans le milieu de
l'humour pitt est peut-être quand tu
prends ta place pour acquis justement
c'est le titre a molli un peuple qui se
fait plus autant de quad originale puis
de son adresse un petit peu notre patrie
aussi de respect que de vraiment lu moss
apparaît comme guillaume le stand-up
jetant ses différents au québec on dit
souvent que les gens adorent lumeau mais
je pense que les jets qu'est-ce qui
adore ses rires puis je pense vie
publique de galles ce n'est pas de
fermer des publics d'humour c'est à dire
public qui aime rire mais pour moi
public comme des musées à moi j'adore la
musique j'en écoute tout le temps que
cette écoute à la radio qu est-ce qui
passa région super était pas un fan de
muse était un fan de son honneur c'est
ça de l'effet sexe un plaisir d'entendre
des notes pour moi le mot c'est un peu
la même chose c'est infâme du mot secte
est capable d'apprécier un peu tout les
estime à 1,7 parlement était capable de
comprendre les faits et des subtilités
les différences entre les jambes bien
mais qu'un terme juste rire le dis que
ça très poreuse pas bon pis pour ceux
qui ont emmené je pense que c'est devenu
un peu des formules des galons voyons un
peu les mêmes choses les
numéro d'ouverture les mêmes types de
stand-up parce que les gens qui venaient
voir si c'était les mêmes de personnes
puisque juste déjà que si je vous fais
moi rêver que l'on y aller avec des
valeurs sûres je comprends exactement
pythie moi cette profondeur le mode ces
différences de style logés comme compris
un peu plus en écoutant mettons sous
écoute parce que le ca showcase toutes
sortes d'artistes avec des scènes
vraiment différent si vous parlez 2010
mots comment ça marche le processus
créatif à claude fait ok c'est celle du
maule toute une gamme de styles tout une
guerre on rapporte une gamme de deux
façons de faire pilotes voitures manquer
ce thème aussi qu'ils commencent à
marche-pied métier facilement comprendre
la personne qui veut rire et une soirée
le tpiy qui qui peut décemment et geek
de du mot puis aussi les flics justement
ça permet ce aussi d'avoir accès à plein
de choses moore puis souvent justement
ya plein de choses sont des flics ce qui
qui vont vraiment dans
dans l'exemple moins classiques souvent
talisman vraiment vraiment établie
ultime étant je pense à gatsby son show
c'est comme à la limite de l'humour puis
de la conférence ou de la réflexion
philosophique quasiment plus ça pose
même la question c'est est-ce que c'est
l'humour outils au même titre que dans
certaines musiques peuvent poser la
question est ce que c'est de la musique
le tai chi et c'est sûr puis puis là on
est quasiment 10 est vraiment pas choisi
mots que tu es le plus la limite plus de
centres est quasiment coincé parce que
tu dis je suis venu ici pour rire pied
georges rimaud à des fautes et puis je
pense que c'est un peu ce que 20 du
monde ont rapproché maintenant c'est
chaud là tout est écouté ce rôle
non j'ai exactement c'est quoi puis les
sujets qu'elle aborde et tout est gelé
pas encore écouté tes la prémisse de son
chose c'est que l'humour est mort le
tient à la rive l'alzheimer entendent
faire du maupuy soissons le stand up
c'est mort
la clé ça comme ça c'est une douche
froide un profil public m'attend plat
fait un an et demi et là dessus alors là
dessus je peux trop mais moi qu'on vécu
tout en réalité j'avais leur âge réalité
point de n'avoir pas se leurrer c'est le
repos moi mais je pense que les je pense
que le parallèle qui te faisait avec la
musique est vraiment bon ce même même si
on brasse ce point là par exemple
quelqu'un qui écoute la radio dans son
char et entendu pop constamment au
mexique pour lui il saisira mettons vont
dans un show de musique et la musique
c'est large salle a le dos large
sacrement mais voilà le show de musique
rap le site en attente c'est d'entendre
layton qui tentent en radio mais que le
show dans lequel tu vois c'est un show
de jazz
ça se peut que tu attendes le refrain
longtemps c'est à cela qu'il est bon
mais je pense que je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs niveaux à cette question là
mais les attentes ça fait définitivement
partie
de l'équation était là même où j'ai vu
est ce que tu dis je les ai vus dans les
ports commencé au début le je me
considère vraiment chanceux qui est déjà
maintenant qu'ils qui se déplace
vraiment pour mon nom et yannick de
martino je suis vraiment reconnaissant
de dessin je les ai vu la différence de
déjà dans un sens ce qui vaut au
spectacle du mot pilot jarry mais il ya
beaucoup de gens aussi qui sont hyper
efficace dans les bars le tien m'amener
pourquoi sa pop pas plus mais en fait
c'est parce que si c'est ça c'est
positivement qu'un petit quelque chose
que ça fonctionne c'est super efficace
mais tu fais c'est qu'est ce que on a
déjà vu un peu puis ça fait juste un an
rue son compteur sont comme c'est
exactement ce qu'on veut si humour on se
déplacer pour humeau s'est déjà vu il ya
le tard et je pense c'est pour ça qu'à
un moment donné quand on propose quelque
chose de nouveau à long terme c'est
secondaire
mais à court terme des fois ça peut
miner le moral parce qu'à court terme
c'est moins immédiat dans la réaction
souvent - le succès comme témoin le
justement grâce aux réseaux sociaux
c'est assez rapide de parce que dix
morts risque que je fais il y avait
commencé il ya dix ans il vivra encore 1
5 6 ans et que ce serait top
mais maintenant que les réseaux sociaux
et même pour quelqu'un qui y parle ni
chez c'est positif maintenant dénicher
je crois pas ce que vous cherchez du
monde qui font à lire sans enfant à
toutes les fois quelque chose de niche
et maintenant il ya des gens qui peuvent
le voir alias et allez ça m'a rejoint
nous rejoindre c'est celle qui veut pas
de sa marge dans le monde qui vont d'un
soir et de mots mais qui m
avoir une relation qui aiment
s'identifier quelque chose qui vraiment
fait pour n'importe quoi il ya plein de
gens qui aiment le slam
il ya des soirées j'avais fait il ya pas
longtemps une soirée slam du monde
l'hélice la mère faisait du stand up
puis 10 mauvaise on faisait du slam away
est le même la fête à télétoon gens
d'ici c'est quoi la france
je suis cadre de nos jours ça c'est le
très frais j'ai des difficultés à me
prêter à l'exercice par exemple moi
aussi j'adore écrire en maître je les
fais souvent j'aime vraiment écrire mais
je trouve ça dur en dessous de 2 de
proposer autant électoraux cas des
auditeurs ou à des spectateurs parce qu
elle s était pas dans un
à une forme artistique l'humour ça te
protège tout le temps à la limite quand
je dis quelque chose que je pense
vraiment je le fais qu'ironie donc si je
ne sais jamais ce que peut être que moi
dans le sérieux si j'ai tout le temps à
part des nouveaux projets je trouve ça
tough le slam au début je m'étais
vraiment dit ok maya maya l'éolienne
c'est tellement c'est devenu un hommage
aux rousses omar sy trouve cela
courageux tout les toutes les jeunes des
cités des jeunes mansouret c'est comme
si c'était des apparences puis je disais
non tu n'es pas encore à triturer un
goût de karaté je vais pas faire la
passe le mot cache-cache m'étais même si
t'es pas littéralement un personnage
comme mettons mettons bellefeuille c'est
clairement un personnage toi tu es quand
même un batterie mettons tout sur scène
dit quand même que sur cinq juge et
c'est une exagération de moi même exact
parce que je conseillais de conscience
j'exagère je l'entendais vous et moi ça
me plairait aux yeux souvent comme une
grande côté me hante com qu'est-ce que
j'ai l'air de dire et puis qu'est ce que
je dis je
non mais j'ai un ton devoir jessy qui
peut sonner comme un peu mais ce que je
dis pas nécessaire mater mais j'aime ce
soit parce que c'est sam sam sam sarr à
limoges elle exagère en spectacle donc
si je deviens un peu personnage moi-même
effectivement mois ci
tu devrais lire un message à un essai
scientifique woking sérieux hein mais
avec une intonation comique les roses
avec ton intégration comique que tu fait
inhumer rôle et il utilise quoi qui est
juste un essai scientifique un match
sérieux mais j'ai avec les ponctuations
dans le temps j'hérite l'audition de
haltes étant une émission à vrak tv je
demande d'information pour les jeunes et
tout la vulgarisation sur un
scientifique qui fait tout et justement
l'audition ils m'ont dit c'est pas 4
faisait une blague ou pour le gagnant
n'avait pas dit que je parlais le gamin
de voyage dans l'espace et maîtrisent
vraiment qu'est ce qui est un peu la
galère
bel la science est essentielle
exploration spatiale une copie je
parlais des trains et je suis plutôt
comme un atout que d'y penser tout le
long il m'a regardé bien ce n'est pas
sérieux puis neige et gel et polluent
parce qu'on n'est pas capable de
conserver un chrono série mais ça décrit
batigère ton ta première audition avait
été cité était sérieux rapiti trouvais
ça drôle d'études est fausse et est
souvent surpris de même déjà et ça je
pensais pas que je demande aux clubs en
hongrie où ben mccalman et houleux c'est
de plus en plus des jeux achetés si ce
qui est arrivé est là moi je me levais
la mariée pour une question c'est tout
est ok je suis sérieux dit je m'assieds
dans un cours de géo jamais comment 11
et puis ma question c'est est jugé
j'avais juste le canado ces lots 1 puis
ok ce hors jeu que je sens que ça
m'arrivait souvent et je les ai vus
dénier excité c'est la seule enfant et
chez quelqu'un d' extrêmement timide
jeudi devenu encore plus parce qu'à
l'époque mon but - si c'est pas trois
airs et mettez jamais entendu parler et
tout donc vous monde amateur et je te
promets métier j'ai tout à l'heure le
guet
c'est un peu perdu même quand j'allais à
bonne place j'avais la rive alors on me
dit que tu attends quand j'arrive 15
minutes on me dit qu'il s'est passé il
faut bouger beaucoup de choses fausses
je fasse attention parce que je suis une
victime des préjugés
déjà ils pètent était juste je me lève
tôt ouais on en parle est à l'heure mais
dans d'antiques du monde je me lève à
midi et demi je te labatt bleue mais
césaire au moins je me lève je t'aime
mon ami julien g lacroix ils pensent
toutes tailles il lui il se lève plus
tôt que moi je me lève à 7h et ils ne me
croient pas au marquage latex à serge
sept ans dirigeait dirigé dans sa phase
6 passes décoincer les visas non non non
ils pensent que c'est moi message
[Rires]
ben ouais bravo et merci vraiment
justement et c'est plus mon kit parfait
pour toi j'ai l'impression en relief est
parfait pour ce ben oui vraiment parce
qu'en plus des tuyaux exactement le ton
que je parle de dé les personnages sont
ainsi pas se perdre
mais lyon langage quand même
sophistiqués donc c'est parfait pour
propos pour moi c'est sûr qu'à la base
je suis un humoriste comédien donc ça
faisait pas je ne sais pas j'essaie
d'explorer de jouer un peu des
personnages mais je prends ma palette de
personnages est pas énorme mais est ce
que est ce que c'est en différant bâton
jouer dans la khl mois versus est dans
la séquence notons que tu fais sur scène
parce que j'ai auditionné pour être marc
gagnon il va pas en tant qu'élément
j'avais voulu jouer nous 12
je ne sais c'est pas vos boules c'est
ses beaux cheveux c'est les soignants
c'est lui qui jouait dans des radios en
face à des nouveaux jets comme écouter
livre kiki ouais c'était son père parce
que je n'avais pas aussi le ouais c'est
ça je suis pas un voyou michel fait il
fait le cam le soigneur de nouveau mais
je pense que le fils de l'autre mais est
ce que c'est pour tout le monde cholet
répondre à chaque fois que dans un
podcast on verra on le sait peuvent les
titans quelqu'un qui arrive avec la
réponse pitié avec un des fois un tout
petit peu gentil doux canessa tôt google
c'est le paquet avec fou qui s'était
comme c'était quoi limengo et cuba genre
souvient peuple si du bauxite les mains
bravo mon goût mais c'est cool c'est
cool le monde qui quittait qui ne donne
l'info mais non mais à t on à pau et
google
bref avec mon nom c'était différent de
sourcing en fait qu'est ce que je fais
ben oui parce que c'est quand même mais
c'est très sûr la société qu'est ce que
je fais moins c'est souvent ce soit en
plus j'extrapole sur une réflexion que
j'ai eus par an sur des sujets souvent
c'est un peu dans le délire mais laïque
moi c'est quand même beaucoup de la
l'exagération mais de comportement de
de ma génération je posais un challenge
parce qu'on a pas le moment de notre
génération
donc c'est quand même différent surtout
du sketch et beaucoup d'humour de
situation là donc oui c'est quand même
différent mais par contre j'avoue que le
personnage est quand même pour acheter
du jeu lightman vraiment servir les
textes donc ce n'est pas jouer un
personnage non plus trop grosse pancarte
je propose ils te ramène un peu parce
que qu'est ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment
mettre de l'avant les textes de bruyne
et c'est vraiment apparemment qui est
assez rigide mais piqué sur la manière
qui veut que ce soient joués en bo1
quand est ce qu'ils entendent mais c'est
pas désagréable au contraire cessez le
feu oui puis c'est le fameux savoir
exactement qu'est ce que la personne est
ce que je sais c'est l'auteur ces deux
producteurs c'est sa scierie c'est con
parce que des fois quand c'est un peu
flou mais j'espère qu'on ne sait pas lui
c'est clair au moins
puis ce sont une fois de travailler pour
lui si call aussi des projets qu'il ya
un chef tu peux acheter
tu peux en fait de mettre beaucoup
d'humoristes ensemble qui si elle pas un
directeur clair ça peut prendre cette
direction et c'est tout le monde a sa
vision artistique tout le monde pense
que c'est quelqu'un qui dit non c'est ça
vous pouvez mettre votre touche à vous
mais dans une certaine limite
ça doit faciliter beaucoup le processus
clairement c'est un show qui promet une
identité forte bien style fort le seuil
à rien d'autre qu'à samba se mouche à ce
sujet ben en fait j'avais projet joubel
j'ai passé l'audition puis j'avais été
comme sélectionné je pense dans les six
blocs y rester mais finalement je pense
s'est réduit à 3,4
sûrement que c'est une question de la
vérité comme dans la short list la
maintenance et au final ça et peut
fonctionner
la caméra et on m'avait dit si justement
ai dit il ya quelqu'un qui est trop
prêtre ton casting puis c'est un peu
plate on sait qu on ait vu parce que
l'audition s'était trois sketches crois
qu'on faisait il était on ne sait pas
quel point tu peux jouer une beaucoup de
personnages
donc ça a été ça réseau c'est à
l'audition originale pour la saison aura
du hockey
et puis par la suite quand j'ai mis je
commence à en parler de tout ça lui un
impact ma carrière et les sketchs oui ce
que j'ai mis en ligne je te mets ma
copine et les amis
il est capable de jouer loin puis le ils
m'ont pris dans un ou deux tiers depuis
la défaite en aiguille j'ai joué dans
plus en plus sèche d'une heure pour la
saison 4 on m'a demandé de me tuer et
officiellement dans le cast de gide non
j'attends tremblé face à lui mais ça
doit contribuer à remplir des salles
aussi je me suis vraiment le jeu bête
probablement vraiment dans ce sens que
c'est vraiment agréable ça doit sado
contribuer je sais pas à quel
pourcentage mais c'est je suis chanceux
ces débats plus et ça me ferait pour de
vrai
c'est une vraie mission est ce qu est ce
qu il y en a pas mal au québec ni des
séries humoristiques à la sketches des
trucs comme ça puis ce qui est vraiment
au dessus de lipides pour qui c'est
drôle les sketchs puis ces gens n'ont
pas beaucoup le
ces salles avec moi ça prend des risques
en moi non je suis très cher vraiment
c'est une série aussi que ça se partage
vraiment bien je pensais pas qu'elle
pouvait maintenant mais si tu prends ton
amilhastre youtube un sketch le celui de
comment cruz et washington qui le met
sous battre les yankees public devient
virale ccc watch qu'ils m'adressent
contestation le savent pas c'est bien
pour tout le monde
un bon temps pour vraiment heureux
d'ailleurs le dessus et est en tête en
tournée présentement je suis assez
monrad agent fait de mon premier one man
show 3 s'appelle le show s'est lu
d'allemagne et son énorme en campagne
évidemment je voudrais tant tu voudrais
essayer de donner un exemple cholet ça
pourrait pas être mieux ton titre le ton
direct parce que j'ai le monde m'avait
dit général michael geoghegan a réuni
willem parler des délais légaux iorio sa
tête a été un titre qui à daniel grenier
ou 6 on fera qui gère aussi les chaînes
à daniela et d'airé à se former le 2nd
set ça doit être au moins mon fiancé
j'adore malki avait cinglé il ya des
chiens c'est un guillaume c'était on
s'expose guillaume ça a été son nom à 20
voyons cinglante que son dernier à
guillaume trop loin trop loin de celle
au garage parce que même quand on est
parti c'était tout à comme un mot là au
début on cherchait un mot paix au début
je les appelais soldats rock
excuse moi c'est que c'est drôle à en
sachant l'aboutissement final de walter
c'est souvent moi que je comprends les
codes pin je fais ok j'ai envie de ne
pas les respecter
seulement il sait aussi que je quitte la
scène sans rien dire
retenons me disaient les fous tu trouves
tu y as a faim il faut tout faire comme
s'ils trouvaient dans la boîte
justement quand je partais à 50e mondial
et oui c'est comme moi c'est ce que gm
ne pense qu'à ça attaque puis j'ai fini
13 ans mais avait comme si seul le la
convention dire est quasiment tout le
monde sait à quoi il faut un type de
chou du mot c'est un mot que je
regardais je dois mes études du mot des
fois c'est de l'humour mais il n'y a pas
d'humour il ya dix ans j'avais déjà
aucun souhait des choses comme je les
plus proches des plus de l'humeur de g
je vais me regarder dans mes affaires
pour un liner de j'ai regardé est ce qu
est ce qui t le gygy trouvait seul luxe
c'est comme si ce mot c'est un job qui
avait jamais vraiment fonctionné sur
sign je sais pas écrire moi l'âme à la
natcom type de show puis en plus c'est
bon là ça paraît vraiment juste titre
pour un titre bon au final quand même
une ligne dans mon temps à mon spectacle
parce que j'explique que pour moi les
dalmatiens sont énormes en campagne ce
projet c'est une erreur car quand
j'étais petit que je fais et c'est une
philosophie de jeu explique que c'est ma
façon à moi d expliquer qu avant de
savoir une réponse à quelques que
j'excelle dans la forêt cet accord donne
les réponses concernant de
l'intelligence et des connaissances que
j'ai de la mémoire ce qu'il enregistre
questions posées sur je me disais mais
moi petit que j'ai fait un lien dans ma
tête
ceci c'est quand même c'est une forme
d'intelligence quelque part avec leur
expliquant un peu que je réfléchisse
comme ceux que j'aime sommes donnés mes
propres réponses avant de savoir sur qui
la réponse loin que j'explique un peu un
puceau dans le fond le temps rodage
comment tu penseras taraude jusqu'en
novembre
le matériel à l'intérieur du show
commence pas mal à oye pas mal le jeu
ajoute ben moi je travaille beaucoup en
bloc le pilote comme les blocs sont j'ai
pas mal sélectionner quel blog que je
vais mettre dans le show mais le
j'ajoute à l'intérieur de ceux-ci comme
des des nouveaux gags puis je dirais
qu'il ya quand même encore peut-être
trois trucs que je veux parler que j'ai
de la difficulté à trouver le bon angle
tous les trucs gérer faisceau vraiment
beaucoup mais mon spectacle je parle
quand même mieux d'être plus personnel
mais c'est super habitudes j'avais envie
de la faire pire cc c'est ce qui me
reste plus à travailler puis ensuite
d'autres sociale à la mise en scène
- la conception et tout est à l'écriture
c'est presque prix qui c'est quoi la
différence justement parce que le film
est en train de faire un sketch versus
qu'entre la signature de la scène
sur l'autre volet de la famille méthon
tu veux faire un sketch sur internet le
ceba 100% même le montage sait cela mais
je trouve 2 1
de l'humour à sketches ah ouais ouais
parce que my même il ya des affaires
défroqué que je tourne
puis c'est le premier sketch j'ai parlé
à d'ailleurs c'est drôle les prochains
risque est qu'on refasse et des cousins
un blog c'est une parodie de podcasts
mais quand je suis arrivé ici nicolas
ait pas de casse comme la liberté de
dire ce qu'on veut je suis en rien à dsk
la potée bout votre forme on peut parler
aux slovaques ont voté être un paradis
aux péages
mais parce que je sais c'est le montage
soit cédée il ya des sketches que je
tourne que sur le coup tu fais là la
caméra tu vaux de suite
puis il ya d'autres trucs tout pensé
aussi juste un micro détails que c'était
même pas volontaire ou même des fois tu
pensais que ça avec corporate de
rajouter succéderont ceux qui disent le
sol mais je trouve que le montage et
joue pour beaucoup c'est pour ça que
c'est important d'avoir un moteur qui
comprennent le moment ça ça vaut
vraiment quelque chose pour des ports du
pour de l'humour à un bon mot même pas
bon montrer c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui
comprend dont timing comique pu tester
une passe dans le folk hanté de quand
monte comme dans le siège du spectateur
aussi forte
j'imagine c'est ce qui fait que tu es
capable d'avoir d'avoir des noms mais
steam et on le fait on s'inquiète quand
elton d'été comme cet été sur scène mais
après ce 44 ans était derrière la caméra
derrière l'ordinateur de montage
prayssacois quand je faisais de l'impro
en fait c'est de l'impro c'est cette
survie pour vraiment ils m'ont dit vous
aidant des joggings mais tout est en
train de braquer la banque pour briller
alors tu es dans ton personnage de 10 à
limiter en taille mais ne put les rires
maintenant que ça agri le sari et
pourquoi que ça arrive au test parce que
toi tu été investis c'était tête d'un
tettey dalmat puisse pas comment
stand-up à ce qu'un stand up et était
complètement loupé t'écoute le public tu
es tout en interaction avec eux tentant
le rire le tout est ok ça ça a moins
fonctionné tu penses à la moquer quand
même à m'amener sorte c'est moche est
quand même beaucoup de coins du work
aussi dans mon show ou d'un brusque mais
j'aime penser que le monde le sache
ouais j'ai fait comme beaucoup plus
souvent ces mêmes les gens la prod qui
dans le public qui mettront vous venez
me voir parce que j'aime ce que mes
seins pro rente il faut se rendre encore
plus fort mais je veux pas que ça rende
pas ce que c'était que c'était drôle
pour vrai bien sûr qu'un stand
interactions mais non mais ça fonctionne
comme ça mais mais juste pour dire quel
point c'est ce qu'un cache pas un sketch
c'est pareil c'est shiller pour vrai
elle chute d'un donc ceci après ce
cessez de me voir j'ai assez drôle que
j'ai fait cette phase là puis s'était
même pas calculé
c'est ça je pense la sainte que tu
calcules puis en sketch du calcul pas
sur ce qu'il faut que soient les
conditions de l'équipe puis comme dans
laïque - d'écouté comme tout le monde
parce que il voilà en train de jouer
point
donc s'ils me disent cammas trop
exagérer yannick ou ice aussi drôle
quand tu y fais ça vaut il faut deux
belles et écoute puis tu le joues
est ce que tu penses que tintin style
puis un dea les bruits qui se prête
vraiment bien alain pro team et on a le
mettons que ça improvisé plutô t une
ligne qui tombe flatte un peu j'ai
l'impression qu'un des livres qui peut
la rendre au camp mais ce qui est pas
tout les humoristes peuvent avoir toutes
ces choses qui tombent un peu plate à
quoi ça va être drôle tu es bon jusqu'au
bout de six mois je pense que j'ai cette
chance nous d'avoir une musicalité qui
est particulière et qui qui qui fait
sourire
je pense que vraiment des fois au début
c'est que ces ententes mort est des fois
qu'elle est les commentateurs se sont un
peu mieux le style milieu des heureux si
au début ces gens on est toutes avait
pas de besoin une job je sais rien dit
oui parce que tu parles tu craches c'est
gentil merci gérard pas de joie où je
mettais déjà fait ça m'amenait youtube
page et avait fait trois spectacles du
nord à 3 et puis astuces comme
maintenant sucre en commun mais moi je
vous faire j'avais avant ça se faisait
pas beaucoup il ya et m'offrait du bruit
qu'il faisait pis aux states la majorité
font ce témoin c'était vraiment peau
pour montrer par année matin le wall se
considérait comme beaucoup mais t'en ben
maintenant la maintenance ou comme je
suis comme devenu pas mal tout le monde
fait ça mais quand j'ai commencé à le
faire c'était comme si c'était gros mais
moi je faisais vraiment pas pour flasher
c'est juste que moi j'accumule
énormément diedrick j'ai besoin de
deadline
je me donnais un deadline c'était pour
moins de 10 mois risque in the wall e le
monde parle pas mal qui est la troisième
heure à trois et mettez tous plus facile
que - qui réunit heures parce que tu
parles moins vite fait qu'une heure pour
trousser une demi heure
j'attends barnak la postulante max mais
non il faut que je fasse deux fois tant
de stocks pittsburgh
un timbre à vie parce qu'il ait beaucoup
moi j'écris beaucoup sur sign met en
congé c'est une idée souvent c'est des
mots clés j'ai comme une idée j'ai pas
nécessairement encore les jo qui je
laissais je me lance
moi c'est les liners mais exemple il ya
justement je testais du nouveau matériel
qui m'a l'insee on est on est toutes des
jeux étaient des bébés
c'est cette idée je vais partir là
dessus et je savais pas comment m'en
servais tu acceptes l'autre des listes
et si le voyage dans le temps et était
possible maintenant comment il réagirait
christophe colomb dans un cours
d'histoire m'étais je n'ai pas encore
que j'ai dit mais ça se construit ça va
les grandes lignes tu arrives loupé trop
des gags souffler oui c'est sûr c'est
plus dans 10 des cas c'est un truc ça
devient un sketch rendu leur latin comme
lui j'étais parti sur l'idée yade se
noie met plein jazz quand on est toutes
déjà été des bébés choisi chose
d'illogique
charles lafortune de gtb belgique un
projet c'est exact le jeune homme des
noms puis je fais jusqu'à 15 quand je
vois que le nom c'était comme hier j'en
ai ajouté pictet cie il faut charles
lafortune digital été jetés comme des
les fruits des bois j'écoutais le cercle
puis il parle à pau lourdes dimanche par
la police a déjà été libéré il n'y a pas
de diag souillac ses singles i
c'est un genre de délire explique pour
moitié d'improviser là dessus et m'a
fait christophe colomb si j'en improvise
mettons cinq minutes mais au final mon
gars détaille-t-on 45 secondes
ouattara gym c'est très coûteux quand je
réécoute fait mais j'ai pas études
besoin de trois minutes qui tourne
autour de sa série y ait un peu tard
bout à des affaires pour emmener sortir
la grosse job mais moi c'est cool
au début tu es tu toujours fonctionné
comme ça parce que ton background
d'impôt qui embarque moi c'est ça ben
j'ai ouï mais je laisse mes moins au
début
au début j'étais très nerveux pour
[Musique]
ce que j'écris bon port marchand ouest
au départ peut-être je laisse mes juste
moi je me faisais moins confiance mais
j'étais pas eu de la difficulté à massot
au puy et créer jeunes et tout le
tintouin d'intel ce un cellulaire ça a
changé ma vie aurait ce qu'avance du
temps des calepins et où je n'avais pas
de perdre des affaires puis à ça tout le
monde est sur leur selle avant de sortir
de sa torpeur sketch a star mais
maintenant avec un essai à tout le monde
et tu le jeu n'hésitez pas parfait mais
avant j'avais plus de discuter alphabet
que pour ça je pense qu'avant si ce
n'est plus des liners les liners ses
promesses et improvise quand ils
contextuel dans un bloc mais justin lane
qui m'attend tunisie effet - jack de
coccinelles au liner
mais mais mais donc au début c'est pour
se faisait plus du liner mais plus que
je suis dit spectacle ans j'ai commencé
à animer je pense je pense assez
classique pour la majorité 10 mauvaise
quand même emmené à animer chaque
semaine je fourni plus de massot au puy
écrire quand même emmené et improvise la
première fois je me suis première fois
que j'ai fait agir rien c'était ma
meilleure animation pas qu'ils puissent
elles-mêmes j'ai trouvé mon naturel
comique en fait parce que je sais que
j'ai eu un déclic
puis je me suis dit aïe je pas de raul
grâce à mes blagues mais mes blagues
sont drôles grâce à - pileux j'ai
vraiment quand samedi que des blagues
c'est pas drôle c c'est la personne
c'est la façon de la raconter et tous
qui est comique donc sa mort j'essaie de
travailler vraiment sur mon aide sur
elle puis de venir sur scène en fait
très près qu'est ce que je suis dans la
vie ou du moins cage blague avec des
amis
donc ça m'a aidé puis par la suite le
j'ai vraiment je me suis mis à écrire
plus qu'avant parce que tu écris live
j'écris la fpi aussi ses cages note une
idée bien à plat ce que je sais c'est
pas joué notre jeu pensé drôle puis aux
pays bas j'écris vrai de quoi équiper
chaque moule de la blague
non j parce que trop c'était
rodea au mot près qu'il y en a qui y en
a que ça fonctionne mieux comme ça mais
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui forge des
humoristes qui voit la facilité avec
laquelle tu peux arriver qu'une grande
ligne puis faire des quadro fx je sais
pas parce que j'ai quand même j'ai la
façon j'écris c'est comme que je dis
c'est des blocs
ouais j'suis pas le gars qui arrive avec
un quinze minutes d'un numéro puis
j'aime pas non plus comme que j'appelle
des fois de le mort à performance il
reconnaît le son texte bout de ses
doigts
ça peut être intéressant à voir qui sont
délivrés dans le tapis et oups ça
fonctionne - sais pas ce que je veux
faire mais quelqu'un que c'est ce qu'il
veut faire mais lui a pas le choix
d'intégrer à la virgule près c'est son
fils est pas moins bonne je suis josé
s'était créé la virgule répit est
vraiment exceptionnel dans ce qu'il fait
c'est vraiment en pot c'est vraiment que
- mon je suis meilleur comme ça le tout
simplement
mais ça c'est moi aussi il ya le style
que j'ai c'est de rester connecter avec
les gens c'est ce qui fait en sorte gg
ratisser plus large
j'ai jamais voulu me dénaturer mais
juste de faire comprendre aux gens que
je suis conscient de qu'est ce que je
suis en train de compter déjà ici que ça
fait 2 me dire que j'étais en train
d'être faire des jokes ecoc réel qui
tient un bout dans mon show que
j'invente des insectes qui serait mignon
jeudi que les uns les uns c'est que
c'est jamais millions d animaux il y en
a 10 millions fait que c'est ce qui
manque aux 1,7 le cheval que tu es pour
sauver la planète de recommencer à
manger des insectes puis puis
puis c'est sympa mais de rester connecté
que les gens aillent
je dis c'est que c'est moche ni modifier
comme les physiques des mots spielt
expliquer ça pendant cinq minutes
c'est spécial quand tu t'attendais à sa
femme à se cogner les orteils sur un
coin d'herbe sous ses différentes mais
et de rester connectés en achetons
jusqu'au ciel de collecte sous le choc
mais ça fait en sorte que j'ai ratisser
plus large plan de caisse qui trouvent
ça drôle c'est me décrochage que là je
te le thème vraiment pour de vrai dans
le moment qui me dit que mes décrochage
s'était dit vrai et c'est un promoteur
pour ouvrir ses ports écrit ces moments
là mais moi je trouve ça me garde jeune
pendant le show pig elle géré pendant
mon amour ou stocks mais je m'amuse
encore plus peut pas vraiment creuser
sur le pilote automatique
mon nom je pense pas que ça me servirait
peas et j'irai chercher moins de man
show man tu dis moi non mais ça existe
un humoriste qui fait son truc qui sans
égard à ben oui et oui c'est bon comme
tu le dis mais je pense je suis quand
même très stand up dans mon approche
dans ce sens que mon jeu
souvent je me prépare pas énormément
belle pour mon one man show c'est
différent mais en général
si je m'en vais jouer au bordel chez les
sujets que je veux parler mais je sais
pas dans quelle heure je sais pas les
liens que mon frère se sent bien sur
sign donc deux blocs
si tu me demande la même soirée sasp
était vu les mêmes sujets mais pas les
mêmes jo qu'à l'intérieur de deux dans
le fond de tes blog mois pour manque
effectivement il y en a qui cite ontex
était si ton texte écrit
c'est quand même comme au même titre que
des bennes qui doivent être le pilote
automatique en tournée c'est ton cette
lettre est écrite gelé tous ensemble
ouais mais peut-être des fois des
soirées qui at elle tourne ça allemande
en plus tripes et on va les plus denses
direction alertée mettre leurs moutons
on parle de musique ajusté maison moi je
parle de moi des fois je fais chier le
monde que je sais qu'elton vendu joie
que je peux aussi ok pas que j'imagine
que même ces quatre textes écrits
peut-être qu'ils maîtrisent accent ou je
sais pas c'est parce qu'il prend le
maquis des compos si différence il
m'était pas un band de méthane gazeux
state trois matches pour l'heure cette
liste selon le public qui le nom même
est un 8 0 est patente
je sais pas
un grand bassin et une passe qui
composent deux centres de soins moi je
veux savoir
je veux savoir qu'est ce qui s'est passé
après les podcasts sous écoute au casque
lorsque ceux-ci vous aussi vous écoutez
ça en ce moment à les voir seul je pense
une carte quantis dessus s'écoute avec
yannick et julien lacroix
vous êtes michaud je pense que mon père
c'est mon deuxième 6 écoute du mois puis
sept premiers du julier je me suis
souvent j'étais déjà allé récemment
lorsque mais on les dons étaient
contents de le faire ensemble gamins qui
ont élevé le coût du risque est là là là
peut-être votre que définie afin de
porter plainte au nom des buvettes à 20
une saga phare après moi mais si je mens
gérer les capacités à isla comment je
suis comme tout des coulisses le ton
enfin j'ai fait trois bières avait ici
et que j'y vois trois ans j'ai bu de la
bière après ça j'ai bu et j'étais
complètement des collines
ouais je me suis gt
et je pense c'est une des soirées je
dois avoir été le plus désagréable je me
disais à l'alcool ça fait ressortir la
personnalité profonde mais non là ça
fait juste amplifié beau justin plus
d'empathie pour du monde que je trouve
déchets trop bu pillées pendant ledit
l'écho ici parce que je vais acheter
moi j'ai forcé sont nés atteints michel
c
si floues -les en soirée est encore
michelle mone cci maman fait embarquer
dans la vanne il m'a donné de l'eau de
giga rocher de l'autre
à ce moment le quand tu rates tu
racontes c'est flou quand tu t'en aller
vers un noir devenu inspecteur je m'en
vais faire mon show du nord - qui est le
ja riise sur place le tout le monde le
titre correct et je me suis dit que ça
se passe
[Musique]
dcb
c'est cette liste et g ok ian et martin
on arrive préparer de l'eau voilà de ce
papier filet j'ai des gars là c'est
qu'ils y arrivent en coulisses et
mathieu ça y est le il vient de finir
son show justin voyant julien il me
suivait akirov savent au dessus
le module est juste mais thiriez je
faisais rhône mange normalement les
fériés pour l'huile ses jeunes pousses
et super g je m'étais on n'est pas de
recul
biya et m'emmène de loger garage est de
l'eau partout pis on va faire un full à
l'aser mais maintient mot juste et plus
conscients d'être sur le michel fait ok
que julien tu feras 15 minutes le juge
qui était julien commencé d'installer le
matériel et c'est bon après si tu
arraches est quand même un peu pareil
sûrement oui mais lui devient comme ok
en fait trois bien non c'est bien ça
fait une bonne différence
je pense que oui bon 3 bien si je pense
j'avais bu wirtz franchement j'ai été en
tout cas le souhait coûte dure 1h30 vous
prenez vous buvez la bouteille au
complet le sait ça s'est un temps d'une
heure et demie c'est pas long pour boire
sur le ventre ou à dénoncer ça sert
offre avec julien fait c'est un truc
mais moi j'étais à côté mais d'à côté de
la scène tu fais des genres des mauves
de karaté métier j'étais plus le monde
qu'est ce qui fait le michel il ya cette
autre guitariste guy forget compte -
l'as bressols il demande à mathieu à
mathieu vos frères vos phares du temps
et dans ce pauvre gars qui viennent
représenter ensuite
et quand j me présenter j'ai essayé de
faire mon stock mais je me souvenais de
rien signer deriez 30 ans de lachenaie
de rien le salage marmonné elle mais je
ressens à rire le tj sérieux
moi je
le monde disait le monde s'ils
réagissaient peu d'actes moi je me
choque est qui risque que vous riez pas
c'est une femme c est drôle c'est pas
moi plus d'être comme émotif sur sign et
leurs pendants christelle c'est drôle
d'habitude j'ai perdu pied
peter aubry sur sign t'es sérieux tomber
le vraiment pas au site il ya un combien
de lancer un peu tête puissant qui était
venu te voir toi points mais en plus si
c'est encore pire c'était pas dit
nécessairement des femmes
on était en c1 mercredi dit-on milieu de
semaine seulement avec des passes de
comédiens puis moi j'ai gagné
l'année d'avant révélation par des ondes
qui venait pas voir yannick de martino
qui venait vaut la révélation du
festival comédiens c'était gênant mais
pas comme ce coup le jeton bataille et
mon micro il tombe à côté de mourne le
tout moment la logique phone
c'est ce que j'ai dit khalil à l'heure
michel viens me chercher il me semble je
veux pas sortir je fais la semoy elias
moi je fais du système d'appui je veux
faire du stand up jeudi à lire il arrête
pas de guérir je veux faire du stand up
pendant ce qui me sort tellement les
comores dorman mathieu sans effet il
essaye de sauver les meubles puis il
commença par son autre match qu'à sa
gueule et c'est un opportuniste asti
c'est mon show c'est mon eau chaude le
sait lui qui joue il est opportuniste le
10 juin
pham thanh tam thaï elle dit il parle
jamais demande normalement ffr la crise
de grippe il
il m'emmenait à ma chambre d'hôtel et il
m'a juste fermé a pas de bonnes nuits
pileux
une non dix minutes plus tard je
descendais au bar aba le y avait un mal
qui était llopis et mikey éco hôtel est
lui même sous les 10
j'arrive y atteler au lait avaient tout
en lui fait les faits tweete quoi boire
mousse party change mais un cadre plus
votre cochon de lait fait 4 up salle
ferrer il commande un cadreur j'entends
la fédé il veut un cadre faisant virgin
syndrome plus que tu veux d'alcool
- ah mais c'est sur le terrain et le
concert à boire michel y arrive il nous
voit vous êtes deux austin niaiseux il
est proche et parce que moi plus le lieu
de montrer comment cette agence
9h40
mon show et n 9 heures à 9 heures à 10
heures un qui demande un comédien voiron
et parce que j'espère
je n'ai pas réussi à faire mon spectacle
votre coup chez astin tide à rien parce
que sérieusement comedia médiatis sa
férule de raconter en plus parce qu'ils
ont été tellement bon et tellement
compréhensif le sari plaît vraiment
avoir un impact de on ne veut plus
jamais cette grosse nos galeries tout
mais michel il était habile pour leur
part les puits ont vraiment comme est
pour rien mais je prends 100% du blanc
parce que riom était tellement en
empathie qui ont pris le blanc ou miro
faire on était stupide de mettre sous
écoute peu après son spectacle c'est
notre faute et est mort sur le coup
c'est moi qui ai dit que vu comme un
imbécile métillon était tellement collé
compréhensif pour 6 a pas eu de
répercussions qui maintenant c'est juste
une bonne anecdote mais une excellente
année amgen ça me gêne vraiment beaucoup
le lendemain matin le titre les couches
et finalement wager de gauche au final
j'avais un galop le gala de catch
réveiller dire le moral les plus jeunes
mais vie pour vous parce que je me
sentais
tellement pas professionnel je trouvais
ce humilié quand je pensais le jeu tu es
vraiment chez comme c'est tellement pas
- je trouve cela humiliant mais chez
kant hcg la haye d'un gros con douche
les espoirs respectueux et pour les
spectateurs c'est me trouvais vraiment
qu'on met 6
c'est fou l'alcool comme access habitat
comme tu dis au yart sujet j'ai pas été
champion plus encore mal mais ça s'est
décuplée même parce que c'est ton ton
milieu professionnel plus sérieusement
j'ai été très chanceux parce que ça
répète du sabotage mais je pense que ce
ça arrive plus souvent qu'on pense parce
que moi je me rappelle avoir entendu des
histoires c'est parce que ça n'arrivera
pas martin matte ça arrivera jamais à ça
ce monde là par contre dans des bords
moi j'ai attendu à mener et à rejeter
dans une halle à jacques gabriel
d'almeida freitas les jeter dans une
loge avec lui puis julien lacroix
puissent raconter un peu d des histoires
de come des fois où est ce qu'ils
étaient sion poétique à définir un show
ces qui a amené ces [ __ ] les bois et
bois et bois pas à fond et c'est comme
ça tu crush pitcho les pommes et
heureusement que ça arrive dans des
bonnes pratiques en salles arrive plus
mais maintenant les bords grâce à
internet et où c'est comme les nouvelles
salles les gens se déplacent maintenant
vraiment pour la personne qui joue
donc je pense de moins en moins en moins
mais effectivement quand j'ai commencé
mais des fois le monde mais ça m'est
arrivé aussi sur scène c'est d'échapper
d'échappement juste pas pu il trouve ça
bien plus drôle d'être sous les
catésiens aux clients à koffi n'a
toujours aucune cm sont caritas à ses
dirigeants qu'ils veulent souvent seriez
mieux partis que quand on lire dans la
révélation comédie aux autres les
connaissances
c'est super pour les autres ils ont ils
pas su que ça arrivait ou spa pas tout
non c'est juste comme il en a parlé mais
tout dans le contexte que c'est c'est du
monde qui vont voir des gars là ils
connaissent pas pu eux ils font jusqu'à
la révélation on va les voir ils sont
c'était un mercredi
donc c'était vraiment un public familial
mais ne voyez aucun doute qu'ils étaient
arrachés wouah non mais non ça rien
parce que j'ai demandé s'il y avait là
un video de sauver j'étais curieux
comédiens ont dit oui parce que au début
n'ont plus tellement on trouvera de
l'envoyer fassi avait tellement à part
alors je vous jugerez avec ça mais non
c'est vraiment voir ce qui est curieux
de voir à quel point parce que cet arrêt
fait mal sûrement parce qu'elle a
tellement flou si ça reste des mémoires
flou je suis pro par exemple dans un
tournoi d'impro vraiment sous la barre
de voir des shows non chaud non jamais
ah ouais tout jeu tout est jeu pas été
capable de définir
je me rappelle il ya des fois le
styliste est le comité va pas si c'était
aussi c'était au boudoir aussi c'était à
l'atelier mais je ramenais étaient comme
des lobbyistes au bout du doigt ah oui
c'est au bout de rappel que tu m'avais
regarder le groupe a également racheté
au regard des années folles comme ont
fini c'est pour mettre un contexte moi
je fais je fais pas dans le show de
découvrir l'enfant la dent bent qu'on
vous dit
les toons leucate connell pour par danse
libre fonctionnement
puis ce seront joués à m'amener au
boudoir chamailleries dimanche puis un
coup de place de même c'était vraiment
comme la brousse de la semaine en même
temps d'être comme on travaille t mais
ça faisait partie du truc c'est qu'on
prenne des châteaux le stage avec
l'amortisseur est passé de l'ambiance
tac effectué grecque mais des fois si on
arrivait à des ce qu ont dépassé la
ligne puis si amélie en plus à champtocé
genre si justement c'est du stand up en
même temps d'être la musique
crissement drôle naturellement plus et
soul plus a dit niaiseries masse que les
loyers des shows il ya des choses aussi
qui est béton je peux pas finir la toune
parce que j'ai trop envie de pisser ses
papiers genre ça m'est arrivé plus des
infos qui ont joué les pires bros été
qu'un horrible renault et dans le temps
le ticket qui ont commencé quand tu es
jeune puisque seulement d'amendé
chaudement domaine des pins est pilotée
comme pour épicer en plein milieu de ses
jambes
ces gens là
des fans du genre je mets la giz
l'apparat course pillage arrive pour la
corde
c'était ont amené la fin du show ont
joué de michael jackson c'est qu'ils ont
la tonne avec le hall des solos les plus
les plus heureux des solos ses jambes en
haleine qui est fait un solo sa toune
tac le team où j'avais crime atroce qui
supplée georges année les petits bleus
la toule arrivera ça moche i have au
chip le parmalat ou non jouer ce jeu
déjà jeudi au micro
ça va chier et le solo ça va chier je
vous le dis on arrive le plus affligeant
genre algues qui essaye d comme le coin
comme l' enfant de 4 à 48 ans vous allez
vous l'avez dit sportif répond à un
échec sans vis comme un humour j'imagine
qu'ils aient l'alcool dans ses caisses à
faire était juste - shocked jeu des
moins bons réflexes pitié en une autre
problème en moins bien interroger avec
le monde ça n'est pas vrai au début j'ai
jamais été cette occasion si j'ai déjà
été sous un nom à passe cette fois le
mais souvent quand même quelqu'un
d'assez anxieux de base et je réussis
dans maintenant à mieux contrôler mais
avant c'était vrai mais qui donc ça m'a
aidé à être dans le moment on a pensé à
commencer dans trois blocs et motrices
elle la prime enfance
le sam aida est dans le moment mais si
c'est la consommation de trop lui même
le corps porte je cache pas oui entre
caisses qui résonne de doute et on
écoutera d'amiens c'est pourquoi elle
ment knievel sous le maillot bleu je
sais pas ce que je sais pas pourquoi
mais andrée que le cac 40 watts et chaud
le but c'est d'eux que tout le monde je
t'ai geôles putois payer chat a
tellement de plus toutes mes shows le
plus à coeur parce que pour une raison x
pacing chuté à du monde qu'est ce qui
n'est pas dans le barman qui est loch
jamais vu de ta vie juste parce que tu
veux tout le monde - mais quelque chose
de comique aussi avoir quelques insultes
sur le super moyens c'est un pur sadisme
et les mecs lui est capable de ces lui
avait un autre sous écoute après sa
chute un nom tout appris mais lui n'est
capable d'être mais moi je le sais rien
marc rouanne oui mais oui qui m'habitait
plaisanté rendant ici mais je pense
c'est moins j'ai regardé mes mains ont
amené les grilles par l'armée de la
vodka chute collective rendent chez vous
le serez complètement des fonds aussi
piteux fait le plus gros bêta soirée
jeux ça va te coucher
c'est juste parce que rendu le sait ces
petites seul le savez ça m'est arrivé
deux fois de rentrer chez nous juste
pensé vous j'achète plus d'alcool
chinois
gso kozuka vendée je rende souche parti
dernier va quand même qu'on ait eu au
bacon aller
à laval ah ouais même si c'était
incroyable c'était genre tu arrives au
board
premièrement c'est une des places les
plus hauts sommets cache-t-elle
quelconque date le fabricant dell arte
deux avantages peu trop c'est comme un
bord à même temps d'être une galerie
d'or qui doit être le spectre le
spectacle un club c'est comme espèce de
grosse affaire avec complèment pavillon
pris au jazz qui jouent peu plus loin
c'est comme la grosse musique pour
danser c'est vraiment incroyable pillent
des oeuvres d'art partout c'est vraiment
ce que c'est vraiment grèce puis tu
arrives l'autre point une carte puis le
tout les drinks que tu prends ils
pointent sans ta carte à puce est
vraiment parfait pour jean l'échappée
qui est si tu perds ta carte coûte 30
pièces six prénoms en boire pour trente
pièces là bas tu sors poelvoorde dans le
prix hubert ont été chauds le vent était
passé 12 kg à stains et staff puis on
était ont été arrachés déjà en 33 de ce
genre j'arrive au bord il ya trois
formats devant le style go un moyen
terme si fait que moi je me dis bah je
vois être raisonnable si je peux prendre
les moyens c'est le juge pointe le moyen
la fille à moins que le groupe moyen
d'un genou gauche a dit stephen roche
est vraiment un choix fait que je prends
je sais pas quel grand club
pis le temps plus les labos les roms ne
coûte rien parce que mal avec le thé a
fait la fête à fait le drink apprend des
bouteilles de rhum fait ce genre garde à
latin ça fait juste monté juste monté à
remplis puis pauvresse être inclus à
savoir le vol eu comme but pendant toute
la soirée
j'ai fini le boulevard royal resort
mes jambes elle échappe dainville
j'aurais été emmené sur l'année passée
sans horizon avec des amis la bosse
comme il est passé du paradis châtelet
de shooter comme ici que la bombe a vite
cédé devant elle
audibof est belle c'est vraiment con
surtout question de l'alcool à volonté
pourrais-tu non-votants convient aussi
bien grandi shah d'iran est prête à
contribuer après plusieurs chefs de
moins en moins quand on parlait du
dernier voire de la soirée de travail en
terrain camping et puis toute la soirée
jeux il y avait une fille qui était qui
était chaud de l'été puis on se parlait
peu on se croise on se creuser au
camping puisqu'on vous dit non mais moi
l'été on se creuse et moi on a faim la
soirée
on était comme chaud quand même pas mal
plage pendant nos devoirs plus le ph au
cdij aurifères sont au vert
je vais juste me n'en fait que la fille
est juste comme 3 quand trois corps
bloqués
west on peut voir des spectacles en
terminant sur mon site web pénis pour
info mais il faut cpe accent aigu et n'y
ait à ce point info.fr fo unef - fo
c'est ça mon site web
parce que en plus ça paraît banal
et puis j'aime et je les dis avant hier
un peu ça ça finit bien la semaine
factice j'assume c'est mon site web lé
parce qu'au début je l'assumé poche et
quand je m'envolais rim mathieu quelque
chose je combats là aussi c'est un
organe séverine de commandes est à la
fête
[Musique]